اما في مجلس الامن فاقد حاله الانقسام دون
اتخاذ قرار بشان التوترات المتزايده في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه ولم يتفق الاعضاء ال
15 على بيان المشترك وبدلا من ذلك دنى عدد
من الدول منها الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وفرنسا بشكل منفصل التجارب الصاروخيه التي
تجريها بيونجا في المقابل دان سفير الصيني
التدريبات العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه وقال انها تغذي دوامه
التصعيد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس الامن لما حد
في كلمتها الى الصين وروسيا على انهما
يشكلان غطاء ويوفران الحمايه دبلوماسيه
لقد فعل هذان العدوان كل ما في وسعهما
لتبرير انتهاكات كوريا الشماليه المتكرره
وهما بدورهما مكان كوريا الشماليه من
الاستهزاء بهذا المجلس لقد سمعنا مزعم
هذين العضوين في المجلس بان الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه قد اجتات
التوترات في شبه جزيره الكوريه من خلال
التدريبات العسكريه لكن هذا مجرد وتكرار
للدعايه الكوريه الشماليه وهي روايه مضلله
العام للامم المتحده
عابر للقارات وعبر عن قلقه اذا توتر في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه
جون سينا
عابرا للقارات فضلا عن وابل من الصواريخ
المختلفه خلال اليومين الماضيين ويجدد
دعوته الى كوريا الشماليه بامتناع الفوري
عن اي عمل استفزازي اخر والامتثال الكامل
لالتزاماتها الدوليه ويحثها على اتخاذ
خطوات الفوريه لاستئناف المحادثات ويطلب
من جميع الاطراف المعنيه ان تتعاون وتهيء
للحوار لتحقيق السلام المستدامه واخلاء
شبه الجزيره الكوريه من الاسلحه النوويه
بشكل كامل
معنى من اوكسفورد ادوارد هاول الباحث
المختص في شؤون شبه جزيره الكوريه
والعلاقات الدوليه في شرق اسيا مرحبا بك
سيد ادوار اين تكمن مخاطر هذه التجارب
الصاروخيه التي تقوم بها كوريا الشماليه
كامل
ومنذ خمس سنوات
لا تاتي فقط ردا على تجارب وتمارين
العسكريه التي تريها الولايات المتحده مع
كوريا الجنوبيه التي تم تمديدها ولكنها
ايضا
الى فقدان كوريا
نوويه لا يجب ان نتفاجئ اذا راينا المزيد
من هذه
التجارب اطلاق صواريخ والى المزيد من
عبارات انوويه
وقد بدات الاستعدادات لذلك اصلا
ماذا تستفيد كوريا الشماليه من اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ
وتلك التجارب
الولايات المتحده ولكن هذا لا يتوقف عند
هذا الحديث
يكفي
الرئيس الكوري الان كوريا الشماليه
الدوليه
ايضا ان توضح الاسره الدوليه
اي جهود ان تبذلها دول مثل اليابان كما
راينا في الاسابيع الاخيره وهي تحاول دخول
في مفاوضات لاقتناء صواريخ تاماهوك وكروز
كل ذلك سوف لن يرضع كوريا الشماليه عن
استمرار بطموحاتها نوويه اضافه الى ذلك
وابعد من ذلك
تستمر بالرغم من كل ذلك بطريقه مستقله
بطريقه مستقله لكن يعني المندوبه
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن ترى ان روسيا
والصين يشكلان غطاءا لكوريا الشماليه
وبالتالي هي رسائل كوريه شماليه في
الواجهه لكنها قد تبدو صينيه روسيه في
الخلفيه ما رايك
انا اعتقد ان هذا دول الثلاثه بدا التدخل
في علاقات
اساسها وركيزتها
المصالح روسيا تدرك وانا كوريا الشماليه
مستعده
لتوفير الذخائر وكذلك المدفعيه مقابل
الحصول على النقد
الصين في ايضا لا تريد ان عندما الاستقرار
على حدودها اذا نعم هناك
جانب دوليه يؤثر في هذا الموضوع ولكن انا
لا اذهب الى حد وصفي العلاقه بين الصين
وكوريا الشماليه
استراتيجيه هي علاقه مصلحه مؤقته
سوريا والعلاقات الدوليه في شرق اسيا من
سبورت شكرا جزيلا لك